[Music]
my name is jean-philippe Mata I'm a
senior software engineer at verily life
science and today we'll be talking about
things I worked on our genomic pipeline
with Apache beam and so the the idea for
today's talk is I'll start by giving you
the background because it's about Rhian
reading DNA or sequencing DNA as we call
it I'll tell you about the little
problem that we'll talk about today the
tools that we have to solve it this is
going to be of course Apache beam how we
solved it and then it will spend a few
slides showing how well it worked all
right so let's get started DNA all right
we all have DNA it's an every cell in
our body we get it from our parents we
have one from each parent
it's we write it as a long string of
letters it's three billion letters
they're going to be ACTG
we have the technology to read people's
DNA I wouldn't say that we know
everything about it we there's still a
lot to to learn if you take two random
people you'll find that there they
differ in about 0.1% of their genome or
their DNA so that's about three million
letters and denna is it's particularly
interesting because one of the reasons
is that the cost has gone down a lot so
you may have seen this graph before if
you've gone to any talk about sequencing
DNA or reading DNA but we'll go through
it quickly so the x-axis is time the
y-axis is cost this is a logarithmic
scale the the Green Line is the cost of
reading the DNA and it as you can see it
has crashed the comparison line in white
is Moore's law so it has the price has
gone down even faster than than Moore's
Law and so now it costs roughly a
thousand dollars to sequence somebody's
DNA so this is fantastic and this means
that we do it a lot more than before
because now it's cheaper Medine DNA is
is really nice for a number of reasons
it's not just about reading the genome
and understanding the ancestry and
figuring out the ways in which people
are different
you could also sequence somebody's
cancer tumor to try to find which
medicine are going to work you can also
do other things than reading DNA using
the exact same technology so one of the
things that people do is they read the
RNA that is active in the cells as
they're creating proteins so what this
does is that whereas the DNA is mostly
static if you're healthy so you get your
DNA and then that's that's what it is it
determines the blueprints of your body
the reading the RNA tells you what this
particular cell is doing at this
particular time so this is something
that you can explore different tissues
different places your body they're going
to be doing different things and then at
different times it may be doing
different things perhaps healthy versus
sick and you do this using exact same
technology so the the price the the
crashing of price means that we can now
do this RNA reading also very cheaply
another thing that people do is you can
because this instrument works so well we
use it to measure other things so we use
DNA sequencing to find proteins so the
way this works just briefly is we can
and by we I mean the field we can
engineer and I'm hopefully I get this
right so I'm a computer scientist right
so we can enter the air an antibody that
will attach this particular protein and
we we can attach a bit of DNA to it so
what we do is we just mix this in the
blood or whatever we're interested in
and then we sequence this we wash it we
wash the remaining liquid off and then
we sequence it and so if the particular
protein was there then the anybody
attached to it and I will find the DNA
that we're looking for so we can you can
read DNA in order to find proteins or
things that are completely that are not
directly related to people's DNA okay so
this is why I'm very excited about
reading DNA the point I wanted to make
here also is that the cost of doing the
lab part has gone down a lot and in in
comparison the cost of doing the
computer part the analysis part has not
gone down as much so in relative terms
the computation is now more important
so you want to spend a little bit of
effort trying to perhaps make it go
faster or cheaper depending on what
you're optimizing for yeah and this is
mplet I'd buy the fact that we now have
even more data than before because it's
cheap so we do it more so we want to do
so computation is relatively more
expensive and there's also more of it so
we'll be talking about some computations
so now let me tell you a little bit
about how reading DNA works just so I
can motivate the problem that we're
trying to solve so a typical lab would
receive perhaps 100,000 samples a year
and the sample would be perhaps a vial
of blood it could be other things and
the first thing you do is you try to
extract the DNA from from this and
amplify it get a higher concentration of
DNA perhaps you'll have ten times as
much as you started from and then we cut
it into tiny fragments and this is
because the machines can only read short
bits of DNA at all so we need to cut it
so the machine can access these parts a
lot of fragments early perhaps 100
million fragments in this example and so
DNA by the way has a direction so we
don't worry too much about it flipping
around and then you put it in the
Machine this is an example machine it
doesn't have to be this one the machine
is going to read this fragments and
there some things can go wrong these
machines are not perfect so one of the
things that can go wrong is duplicates
so bits of DNA can show up in the output
as if they were they're twice as much as
they really are in the sample and this
is the problem that we're going to work
on in this talk so one of those reasons
this can happen is there is a there's an
optical part in this in this process so
the picture here symbolizes a bit of DNA
and on the top are the reads so you you
recognize these are the letters I told
you comprise DNA and if if the thing is
a little bit out of focus it's possible
that instead of seeing you know one dot
of light it thinks there are two dots
and so that would mean that every each
one of these now shows up twice in the
output and this can happen you know as
much as for 25% of the reads so it's
significant and it's a problem because
when you do the end
analysis you really care about the
relative ratio of the particular of each
particular bit of DNA and so if these
ratios are out of whack because of
errors your analysis may be wrong or
it's slightly off target so we want to
detect these duplicates and remove them
so that we can restore the independence
assumption that underlies some of the
analysis that you want to run downstream
now for the context here is how the rest
of the bits happen so the the first
image here is in the machine so remember
we cut the DNA into these small
fragments then the machine is going to
read from each end of the fragment going
inwards and the it can only read roughly
100 bases down and so they won't
actually make they won't meet in the
middle they will just read a little bit
and then the machine has to stop so you
have these two reads that that we know
they're close to each other in the
genome and so we say that they're a pair
they go together and of course then we
flip them so they're at the right spot
so the the green box onward is what
happens outside of the machine this is
now part of the computer stuff and so
the first thing we do is we we flip them
right side up and then based on the
letters that we see we're going to
there's of course more letters than just
shown on the slide we're going to
compare this to the reference genome and
figure out where in the genome
this particular reads should be so this
R is represented by the number here on
the left and you see the dotted line so
the first one starts at position 100 of
course we'd also say which chromosome
it's at here I'm simplifying for the
talk
so you have the position for each and
then because we multiply we amplify the
DNA at the first stage you know you
don't have just one strand of DNA in
there so it's possible that they overlap
and so you can use this overlap to
perhaps find errors so one of the errors
that the machine can do we already
talked about duplication another error
they can make is just miss read one of
the letters so perhaps you have two
reads like the two well on the left here
in the red box that overlap and then you
would expect the letters to be the same
and in this case there is one place
where they're different so this could be
because it's one from the father one for
the mother or it could be because there
was a reading error and
so if you have multiple reads that
overlap and you have removed the
duplicates then you can perhaps use
majority rule or something like this to
figure out you know what's what's the
reality there in which part was an error
so this is an example where removing the
duplicates matters and yeah so if I like
this maybe fifty gigabytes or so just to
give you an idea of the scale so there
what this looks like in the computer you
know on the top I have the symbolic
representation you have the helix of the
DNA and you have the reads that we found
so on the computer you know from our
point of view here today it's just a
record with these four fields and
importantly if two weeds come from the
same fragment of DNA so they're both
read from at different ends of the same
fragment of DNA we say that they're
paired and we're going to give them the
same name this is how we know they're go
together and there is a paired flag that
we're going to set to yes so that we
remember that these go together I
represent them with warmer colors for
the reason our paired and a cooler color
for the reason or not but you don't need
to remember this so all right so here's
the takeaway from the biology so you
don't need to remember the biology but
all that really matters from the point
of view of the computation we'll be
talking about is that the data structure
we work with is a set of read records
and these read records have the fields
that are here on the screen importantly
they have a name appear flag and a
position and if two reads have the same
name that means that they are paired and
they're purified is going to be set to
yes the task is to set the flag that's
circled here called is duplicate because
we're looking for the duplicates I will
tell you in the next slide what are the
rules for doing this and the output is
of the same form it's a set of Records
but now we filled in this form this
field alright so the rules now this
light looks a little bit busy but bear
with me this is actually fairly simple
we're comparing reeds and that they can
be paired or not so there's there's
three cases either they're both unpaired
or both paired or one of each will do
each case at a time they're just the
different rows so the first case is
unpaid
so suppose you have two unpaired reads
the rule that we use is simply if they
both have the same position that then we
say there are duplicates and we're gonna
mark one of them and I represent this in
the example in the middle column you can
see the the green and blue reads here I
aligned them to the same horizontal
position I'm using this to symbolically
represent the fact that they have the
same position in the genome so their
position field has the same value so
they're duplicates and so I circle one
that we're going to mark as duplicate
column on the right shows an example of
a non duplicate they're offset they
don't have the same position so we don't
mark them now for pairs the middle row
the rule is that both positions must
match so if you have paired reads if you
have two pairs then the position of each
element of the pair must match with the
corresponding element from the other
pair so you can see in the example here
I have a greenery pair in a orange pair
and they must align on the left and on
the right on the the other the counter
example on the right you know you can
see if any one of them is offset then we
don't mark anything the final case is
mix if you have one paired read and one
unpaired read then it's only the
unpaired we that's going to get marked
and it's going to be marked if its
position matches either of the of the
elements of the pair so it's always kind
of the same rule it's just if there's
only one position it's the position must
match we have two positions both
positions must match and if it's a mix
you know one of the positions must match
so that's that's the rule that we have
to implement and now before we start
talking about tool I want to give you
just a quick kind of overview of the the
landscape of things that you could use
this is very high-level it's kind of my
own way of thinking of it so the way I
think of it is is on the on the one hand
on the left you have what I'm calling
servers as a service this is where you
use the cloud just to rent a computer
and run you think your thing on it and
so you can take an existing program and
just put it there and it'll work just
fine this is the easiest thing to do
because it's very familiar and so this
is great
for example if you already have some
existing legacy already written software
you can just run it there as is you
would perhaps use it to like kubernetes
in life science we have developed our
own tools there is Cromwell and they
really we put together DISA which is an
it's for our uses it's a simple tool for
running things on the on the cloud on a
server or you may want to go a little
bit further down the abstraction or out
and use what I'm calling a database
centric approach where you use a
database abstraction that the cloud can
give you such as bigquery and so here
this is great when your data is mostly
static perhaps you've already done the
analysis now you just want to present in
in fancy way and you want to be able to
have multiple computers serving the data
so people can go and look at your your
results and the one on the right is is
pushing the abstraction a little bit
further now that's the data flow
languages so the data flow languages
allow you to get a lot of parallelism
and the idea here is that we are now
representing your computation this for
your computation we're representing it
as a graph where the nodes represent
things that happen to the data so
computation and the edges represent the
data flowing that's why we call them a
data flow language so in this example
picture here we have three different
things that happen to the data and the
data kind of flows from one to the other
and there are multiple such languages
there's Apache beam that we'll talk
about you may have heard of spark also
so the you get parallelism because you
know each of these three steps here in
the picture can be done at the same time
each of these are maybe different
computers running at the same time and
also each individual step can be done by
it can be done in cooperative manner by
multiple computers so let's give you the
punchline of the talk already so we
started from non-optimized
some single server running this thing
and then we wanted to write it with beam
and we did and the result is five times
faster at only twice the cost so we're
pretty happy with the result but let's
see how we did this why did we choose
Apache beam Apache beam is is good when
you
when you're working on a large set of
elements that are all of the same type
this is the case here with the genomics
read we have a large number of them we
can process them in parallel this is a
common pattern in lab science and you
may recognize the same pattern in your
own field you know it's not uncommon to
have many receipts or images or
purchases or or clicks or views or ad
impressions things like that the best
way I know to to explain Beam is through
an example so we'll just jump right in
so suppose what you're trying to do is
so still in the genomic context that
we're talking about suppose we want to
know four for each position in the
genome how many reads do we have at that
particular position so an example here
we go from left to right on the Left we
have storage with our set of reads there
are two blue reads at position 12 and a
red read at position 20 the way you do
this with beam is you would start by
grouping by position so group by would
put elements together that matched the
thing that you specify so position in
this case so you end up with two groups
a group at position 12 a group at
position 20 and the next step you would
do is you would say now I want to count
how many elements are in each group and
so the you get your answer at position
12 I have two reads the position 20 I
have one we're done that's what it looks
like it's a very simple example of
course but at least I didn't give you a
word count now this is the abstraction
right so what happens when you run this
in beam is that your code remains simple
so your code is I put pseudocode here on
the left it matches kind of these simple
concepts but the runtime can actually
leverage the simple description to give
you parallelism so you saw where whereas
before we had one yellow dot
representing one computation you know
when you hit run it ends up being
multiple machines I put two on the slide
for space so what can happen is you know
the the compiler recognizes that you're
trying to do an operation and every
element this can be done in parallel so
let's do it
it recognizes are you're reading these
files from the cloud well it so happens
that the
replicates files for availability so we
can actually read from different
replicas to get more performance and it
will do all of these things for you
transparently one cool thing it can do
also is actually it can watch your
computation as it goes and potentially
add or remove computers to tune things
as it's going so I wanted to say in case
you're familiar with MapReduce this this
may look very familiar to you
and so indeed the Apache beam is
actually it's a generalization of
MapReduce so in the sample example it
looks the same but beam differs in I
would say 2 way the first is that
instead of just being one map in one
reduce you can do an arbitrary number of
these together in the same program
without having to do anything special so
it doesn't have to be two steps and the
other difference is it has more
operations than just these two so let's
go through some of the operations that
that beam can do so here's an example
beam program it's a graph they all look
like graphs this program is completely
artificial it's just there to show the
different things that beam can do so
they're the first computation here
marked a I wanted to show that beam can
have multiple inputs coming in to the
same computation and multiple outputs so
you're not limited to simple graphs and
when you send to multiple places it
could be you send the same data to
everybody you have different sub
computations that you need to do in the
same input or perhaps you send different
different subsets of your data to
different sub computations perhaps I
don't know all the green images do some
get some processing and all the blue
images processed in a different way so
that's multiple inputs and outputs the
next dot B circle here shows the map
operation you apply an arbitrary
function to each element so in the
picture here I'm just bolding them of
course you know you can write arbitrary
code you just write every code you like
to process the elements and when you put
this in beam will know to put it on
multiple computers and apply this to all
the elements in your collection you can
also add or remove elements from a
collection so this is the the next dot
here you see if I did the Packman shape
and removed another
the next one D is combining combining
here I'm showing just the count so we
have three shapes and I get the count
there's a number of built-in combiners
you can do max you can do a some minimum
obviously but the the neat thing is
actually you can write your own so so
any piece of code so long as it's
associative and commutative the beam
will know how to run it efficiently on
multiple machines and run a little
computation tree aggregation tree and
get you the right answer efficiently and
you don't need to do anything you just
specify the aggregation function the
final one on this slide is actually more
but the final here we're talking about
is is group by you've seen goodbye
before we're grouping by a position so
it takes a set of elements and it gives
you a set of groups of elements group by
in beam actually has another really nice
feature that I just want to mention now
and even though we're not using here is
that Apache beam can run in a streaming
mode
so instead whereas in a normal usual
computation you have some inputs and you
run it on your program and you get an
output and you're done in a streaming
computation the program just keeps on
running forever conceptually
and you have inputs coming in as
streaming in perhaps they're
publish/subscribe events or clicks or
things happen in the world and then your
program computes things and they spit
out the back continually so you can use
goodbye for this you can group by time
window so you can get like a daily
summary or something or you can also
group by again a sliding window so you
know the number of sales in the past 10
minutes things like this so okay so this
is the overview of what beam can do
there's more but but hopefully this
gives you a good taste and a good idea
of what it can do and when you write
beam you can write it in actually
multiple languages you can have your
choice there's Java Scala Python or go
and I use the Python and here's what the
sample program looks like in Python it's
it's fairly straightforward the one
thing to notice is that the group by is
now two lines what happens is goodbye
doesn't take arguments
instead what you do is you write your
data as a tuple where the first element
of the tuple is what you want to group
by and then you just call goodbye or a
group by key and it's going to group by
the first element so you have you write
these two lines to do your group by and
you can see here the the file names
start with Gs that's path for a storage
on Google Cloud storage so I could say a
lot more about beam I just want to focus
on my favorite features and so the the
first one here is that beam is a little
bit unique in the sense that when you
write a beam program it can actually it
will actually kind of cross compile it
to different runners to different other
distributed systems so the one on the
left is not labeled but this is Google
Cloud dataflow so you would use this to
run it on the cloud you can also run it
on Apache flink
or spark or a number of other ones so
this is great because this means that
the state you write the same program and
you could write you could run it on your
local cluster say using spark or you
could run it on a Google cluster using
Google Cloud dataflow or you could run
it on somebody else's cluster using one
of these other systems and you know if
if one of these systems develops some
great innovation and become super fast
you can just choose to use this one so
that's really nice the other thing is
the auto scaling I already hint hinted
at before so the this graph shows this
kind of integral ways this is what you
actually see when you're running here it
was just a toy program but the idea is
that it will add and remove computers as
needed so there are two lines here so
you may be curious the green line
represents the number of computers that
the system decided was optimal and the
blue line is the number of computers
that were actually running at the time
so you can see the blue line just kind
of quickly matches up to the the green
line it just takes a little bit of time
to start and stop the computers and you
can see this particular computation you
know it has multiple phases there is
some sort of perhaps set up at the
beginning when you have a small number
of computers and then the computation
ramps up and the system adds machines as
needed and it looks like there is a
third phase at the end where we're doing
something else that doesn't need quite
as many machines and so they quickly cut
down the number of
this is done automatically all you have
to do is is you know enable auto scaling
and then you can just see what happens
the third thing I wanted to highlight
about Apache Beam is the many connection
options so I already mentioned that you
can read from a file on the Google cloud
with Google Cloud storage you can also
read from other peoples clouds you can
read from a database you can read events
from publish/subscribe system you can
even this would be for the streaming
case I mentioned before you can even
connect it to another another data flow
language that's going to be streaming
events at you so you can imagine running
Apache Kafka to get some events
streaming through the system and you
perhaps for some reason already wrote
this in Kafka then you want to do some
additional processing in Apache beam
while you can connect the two and the
events flow through and now you can do
your streaming computation and when
you're running beam if you if you're
running with data flow then this is what
it looks like I know that the picture is
perhaps too small to see the details but
I just wanted to give you an overview
anyways so the the biggest part here on
the left is a graphical representation
of your program that's the one you gave
in when you type in your program beam
programs or graphs and each box is
labeled with the name that you gave it
these are your functions and it gives
you some information about whether it's
running or not and how fast and so on
and on the right you have some overall
statistics about your job it tells you
how many computers are running it so
that's the worker count it tells you how
many resources have been consumed so far
some options that you specify on the
command line are repeated here and then
you have the auto scaling graph in the
middle I already explained before so as
your computation is running you can see
how many computers are assigned to it
and you can choose to use it with
scaling or not if you don't it's just
going to be a straight line so that's
our quick introduction to apache beeman
and hopefully I made you want to see
more and learn more and and now we'll go
through this example of marking the
duplicates using Apache beam so you can
see what it looks like in action so just
a quick reminder right we have the set
of read records and we want to mark we
want to update the is duplicate fields
and
rule is that if they're unpaired and in
the same position we mark them as
duplicate if they're paired and both of
the same position and if there are mix
then if there any of the position
matches we mark it as duplicate that's
the rules let's go
so here's a first beam program to do
this so our input on the left is the set
of read records and the first thing
we're going to do is is check whether
they're paired or not we have the paired
flag then we're going to send it to the
different branch so let's start with a
blue branch at the bottom where the case
where they're not paired so when the
reason not paired we're going to use
group by to put together all the reads
that start at the same position so we're
grouping by position and then we look at
each group and we look at how many
elements they are if there is more than
one we found duplicates so we mark them
and then we're done goes to the storage
on the end so our output set of read
records again in the case where they're
paired we need to do a little bit more
work the first thing we do is we group
them by name to put the pair's back
together remember if two rays are paired
they have the same name so doing this we
get the pair's back then once we have
the pair's we group the pair's by their
position to poles to the position of
each half and if you have more than one
in the same group that means that both
of their positions match so they're
duplicates so we mark them and we're
done so this is hopefully fairly
reasonable I'll go through an example to
make sure that we're really on the same
page we'll start with the unpaired read
example so here we have three reads
there is blue green and dark blue and
the blue and dark blue are both at
position 100 and the green one is at a
different position so we checked yes
there are not paired so we go in the
blue path and the first thing we do is
we group them by position so we end up
with these two groups here there's a
group of position 100 and a group of
position 400 you can see that the first
group has more than one element these
reads are duplicates so we are marking
every one except the first one
representing this by circling them in a
picture this means we set the field to
two true and we're done now in the case
of paired reads this time here I give
you four reads to yellow and to read the
the two
have the same name they're paired to the
two red likewise and their positions are
100 and 400 so the first thing we do is
we group them by name so you can see now
we we put the pair's back together so
the you have the yellow pair and the red
pair if there were any more they would
be there the next thing we do is now we
group by position so it so happens in
this example that both pairs have the
same positions they're at 100 400 so
this group has more than one element it
means we found a duplicate we mark it
we're done so this is great and it would
work except that there's a case we
didn't go through you you may have
noticed this we may have been wondering
what I was presenting what about if we
have reads that are paired mixed with
Rize or unpaired but there's a rule
there that says we have to mark some of
them so we need to add this for the for
the program to work so let's fix the
program so here's the exact same program
except now I'll remove the details from
the boxes and I just put a one-line
description of what each box does but
it's the same program so the fix is the
following you first check if the reads
are paired or not and then you send all
the reads down the unpaired check
because when we need when we have the
unpaired reads we need to mark them as
duplicates if they match another
unpaired read but also if they match a
paired read so we're kind of merging the
red and the blue paths down here at the
bottom this way and put it in purple so
now we can check the unpaired read
correctly and write them down in there
and the top part remains of course so
the paired reads we still need to put
the pair's together and do the
processing and everything so this is the
correct fix this would work I've run
this but now you may be wondering well
you know these paired reads are going
through both paths where looks like
we're doing some redundant computation
could we optimize this a little bit you
know could we change the program such
that instead of sending all the paired
reads to check we perhaps eliminate some
paired reads that can't possibly be
duplicates in this first purple step and
then only send the remainder to the read
step instead of sending them all
suggesting this is that yes you can do
it the the key insight here is you know
what can we do when we only have half of
the pair so if they're unpaired of
course we can do the whole thing in the
example here right I have the green and
the blue Reid aligning them vertically
to represent the fact that they have the
same position these are duplicates if
you have paired reads here for example
the yellow and orange
I put the dotted line to show that this
is half of a paired read we can see that
the these two are the same position they
are aligned but we don't know what
happens to the other half of the pair so
we actually don't know whether they're
duplicates or not they could be
duplicates or they could be non
duplicates at this point we really can't
tell the orange read at the bottom
instead this one we know it can't
possibly be a duplicate because remember
the rule is that both halves have to
match right and at this position there
is only one read so we know that because
this half doesn't match it doesn't
matter what happens to the other half
this particular read cannot be a
duplicate so we can eliminate it so
that's the inside we only need to take
the reads that are in this middle case
and and send them for further processing
to double check if they're paired or
sorry if there are duplicates or not the
rest we're done and so just quickly here
is what the program looks like I know
the slide looks busy but this is very
similar to the program we've seen before
work through together before it's just
vertical because I had to fit it we
start at the top left the reads come in
we group them pay position and once we
have this we can correctly marked all
the unpaired reads that are duplicates
and then what about the paired reads
well we look is there more than one at
this particular location if there is
more than one then we go yes and the
paired reads go to the red path on the
right so because these are the ambiguous
case there is more than one they could
be duplicates we don't know if there is
one or fewer then everything goes to the
output that we're done with those
the right path is the same as before you
put the payers together you check their
positions if there is more than one at
the same position you mark them as
duplicates we've seen this it works all
right
so just to make things a little bit
concrete here's what it looks like in
Python this is actual code taken
straight from my editor it's incomplete
of course the full program wouldn't fit
but this is just to give you a feel so
that the text that's bolded is actually
comments it's the name of the of the
stages of the boxes and so this is what
the names that will show up in there in
the GUI and then I call the code they're
all in the beam namespace and you can
see the what we do so here there's a
function I'm calling keep only if has
mapped mate so I only keep the paired
weeds and then the the step one will put
a key in it that represents the name and
so I'm grouping by name and then I'm
putting a key that represents the
positions and then I'm grouping by
position this is step four this is
exactly as we described in the box then
we mark the duplicates and we're done so
of course we need to fill in the
functions there are plenty of examples
on the web but this is what this
particular program looks like and it
gives you a flavor so there's one more
thing I did that I need to mention for
completeness by default when you run
this on the cloud this is for dataflow
in particular it will assign each worker
250 gigabytes disk turns out for this
work this was more than necessary so are
shrunk it to 85 disk so now we need less
storage and so it's going to be cheaper
and here are the results of the
optimization steps so what I'm comparing
here is the original fixed program that
we've seen in the talk it's still
running beam and then the optimized beam
program so this is Apache beam on both
sides this is just the impact of these
two optimizations we did first shrinking
the disk size and second the algorithmic
optimization I walked you through and so
what we can see is that we're 43 percent
cheaper so almost half the costs with
these small changes third of that comes
from shrinking the disk
and another 2/3 from the optimization
that we walked through and the other
thing that I wanted to do is compare
this program against our original
program that was running on a single
server so this the single server program
was running off-the-shelf software I
using genomic libraries and stuff and I
must emphasize it wasn't particularly
tuned for performance and I'm comparing
it to our optimized Apache beam program
and of course this is our own versions
right I'm not making any promises aim
thing will happen to you if you port
your programs to beam this is just what
happened to us and what happened to us
is we're five times faster 5.6 times
faster the cost also went up but it went
up only to X so I have this graphically
here on the on the slide the green bars
show the time server on the left
actually beam on the right so you can
see the time and just crashed down and
the cost on the right in blue
so again servers left the beam version
is on the right the the cost roughly
doubled but the absolute numbers are not
that high so what I you know what's not
in these we like we like to focus on the
numbers right but do another thing
that's really important perhaps even
more important is that the program now
is a lot simpler because this program
now just need to focus on the business
logic in our case that is marking the
duplicates all the parallelization and
the distribution and the fault tolerance
and all that stuff is done by beam and
dataflow we don't have to worry about it
so this is something that I really
appreciate and then we have this other
side bonus which is we have now a
trade-off between speed and cost because
we can choose to set the number of
workers the number of computers that are
running our program so these numbers I
gave you are 490 workers but you can
also run it for different numbers of
workers so what I plotted here is so
each dot represents the average of five
experiments with a set number of
computers so I went from 15 220 workers
and they measured for each of these I
measured how much it costs and how long
it took so the x-axis is the cost that's
kind of how much you put in
and the y-axis is the the runtime so
world clocks just measured overall so
you want to be kind of left and low and
and what you can see and this is
actually a very common pattern is that
initially as you add workers your
performance improves dramatically and
your cost only increases a little bit
and that's because there are parts of
your program that paralized really well
and so as you double the number of
workers these parts take only half the
time and so now your program is a lot
faster in an extreme case you can
imagine that perhaps all of your
computation is like that and if that
were the case then when you double the
number of machines your running time
would completely have and because you're
built by the second your cost would be
the same so we'd be putting twice as
many computers be going twice as fast
for the same price so this is the ideal
case here of question reality there's a
little bit of a slope and what you see
is as you push this forward as you put
more and more workers now the parts that
paralyze well are already shrunk to a
small amount of time so they don't
represent a large part of the
computation time and the remaining parts
perhaps don't paralyze as well and so
they're going to be relatively larger
part of the time and so the curve
flattens up that's what you see it
starts out really steep and then it
flattens and at which point is best for
you really depends on on how much you
value time versus money this is the
trade-off that only you can make another
way of representing the exact same data
is as a as a ratio so you can look at
how much more expensive than the thing
we started from and how much faster so
here I put in red the original program
are started with the blue dots are the
same as before so every dot represents
the average of five experiments for a
given number of workers and so the the
dotted line represents kind of a what
you what you might expect if you were
taking the original program and just if
you were able to run it on two machines
and get it twice as fast so the dotted
line represents this linear speed-up of
you know if you double the cost perhaps
you'll get twice the speed
but of course in our case this is not
the same program this is a completely
new program that is written you know
cloud native and beam it has different
characteristics and so what we see is
that it shifts kind of up into the right
it's more expensive but much faster and
as we add to the number of workers it
goes up if if I were to add more I
expect this would flatten flatten out I
just didn't run the experiments with
more so that's what it looks like just a
few takeaways so the you know if you can
remember just one thing about Apache
beam is think of it as it's an
abstraction about how the data flows
through your computation and putting
your computation in these terms allows
it to get really high degrees of
parallelism and performance this is
really good when you're computing with
lots of data items that are the same
type this is a common pattern in life
science you may also see it in your
field the most common operations are
grouped by and map or parallel do and so
group I will put together elements that
match in some way that you specify and
the other one will is when you want to
do an operation on every element in the
group or in the collection there's more
have you seen what you mean beam is
great when you're writing a new program
you can write your program in this is
this cloud native way if instead you
already have you know a large amount of
software that you can't modify you want
to run as is on the cloud perhaps you
want to use something else that lets you
just rent a computer and run things
there like kubernetes or our very own
d-sub that's an open source tool
[Music]